stuff your stockings and load your
shotguns because grand theft auto 5 is
getting dangerously cheery this year's
festive seasons greetings and shootings
to GTA online GTA flares on ps4 xbox one
and pc will find Christmas trees in any
home apartment or yacht that they own
there's also a group of festive trees
standing in Legion square expect a
snowball fight or two to break out when
the weather hits you can also deck out
your avatar with new holiday masks
including bad elf festive luchador crazy
gingerbread and mr. and mrs. Claus there
are Santa outfits and pajamas and
Christmas themed car horns to try out as
well the festive surprise 2015 is only
releasing for current-gen systems but
rockstar stated that special clothing
from previous year's events will appear
on all platforms you just might get to
wear those Kris Kringle PJs on your ps3
or xbox 360 the festive surprise is
available now and runs until January
fifth if you want to channel that
holiday spirit while imbibing some
liquid spirits now's the time from all
of us at gamespot have a happy GG a
holiday